sie haben ja auch eben zugehört ist die
stimmung bei ihnen ähnlich oder sind sie
entspannter
ich muss sagen ich bin da entspannter
ich habe jetzt selbst jahre das
reisebüro vor elf jahren gegründet und
komme aus dem fußballgeschäft
war teil des geschäftes und habe halt
ganz gute kundschaft die mich dahin die
sind ganz gut unterstützt sie sehen ja
unser büro hängt voll mit bundesliga
trikots und da bin ich auch sehr dankbar
dass jungs auch in so einer zeit dann zu
uns halten
das muss man noch mal erklären also ihre
hauptkunden sind bundesliga profis und
bundesliga profis wollen wahrscheinlich
auch was erleben die gehen dann zu ihnen
und sie stellen dann die besondere reise
zusammen oder weg was wie verizon
bundesliga profis wir müssen das so
verstehen wenn man teil des geschäftes
war ist man eben auch im geschäft ganz
gut vernetzt deutschlandweit und wenn
man mit denen selbst zusammengespielt
hatte ich war selber drittligaspieler
und dann ist man halt in diesem kreis
fußballprofi irgendwo jeder kennt jeden
das ist eine große familie und die jungs
wissen halt was ich ja ich sag mal wie
ein fußballprofi denkt und was er möchte
worauf er wert legt im urlaub und
deswegen kontaktiert hat mich jeder oder
viele von den jungs die mich persönlich
kennen und das läuft halt zu allen
uhrzeiten des tages und teilweise spät
in den abend dann hinein auch gerne per
whatsapp also muss man schon sagen die
jungs sind gut drauf haben 100 prozent
vertrauen und deshalb läuft das auch
hier
und was gibt's denn da so für wünsche
verreisen die anders als an kempkens
oder ich dafür kann ich sie zu wenig um
das beurteilen zu können im vergleich zu
ziehen aber die jungs legen halt wert
nach einer anstrengenden song vielleicht
50 55 spiele des jahres muss man schon
gucken dass die ernährung stimmt dass
das hotel mit fitnessbereich stimmt dass
meine laufstrecke zur verfügung hat das
alles sehr sauber ist möglichst im
fünf-sterne-bereich sie können sich
vorstellen dass wenn ein fußball profi
zu hause lebt er lebt gut ist die ganze
saison über unterwegs in guten hotels da
möchte natürlich keine abstriche machen
und dann muss man halt die richtige
hotellerie finden und da bin ich halt
ganz gut vernetzt kenne alle die meisten
klubchefs oder hotelchefs und deswegen
läuft dass die haben 100 prozent
vertrauen ich suche den urlaub aus und
kann ich bei ihnen auch das goldene
steak bestellen wie für franck ribéry ja
wir sind so dass in dem bereich der
prominenz bin ich jetzt noch nicht
vorgestoßen der heute prominenteste sag
ich mal ist maik franz und und eduard
lügen
die zwei jungs aus der bundesliga zu
reparieren habe ich noch keinen kontakt
gehabt aber auch das würde mehr in
bochum also das gold ist die kann man
bei ihnen buchen aber wenn noch mal wenn
ein bundesliga-star verreist was zeit in
der so viel pro person also wenn ich
verreise ist das so zwischen 500 bis 1 5
aber das wird wahrscheinlich sehr sehr
wenig seien im vergleich zum
bundesligaprofi ja sie müssen ja jeder
beruf hat seine diskretion das muss ich
natürlich auch waren ich darf keine
preise ziele preis geben und auch keine
reise beträge aber dass die natürlich
auch ihre luxus haben das ist gewiss
genau nicht mehr als sparfuchs wenn ich
also für viel geld verreisen würde wäre
das ja auch irgendwie komisch
er wird also sie klingt eigentlich ganz
gut drauf machen andere reisebüros das
falsch also ich kann nur für mich
sprechen
ich spreche aber auch trotzdem für die
branche denn meine kollegin
vorangegangen die hat ja erzählt dass
die dass die provision zurückgebucht
werden
da können sie sich vorstellen den vier
monate abgesagt werden und man hat ein
jahr im endeffekt dafür gearbeitet
versteuertes geld wird wieder
zurückgebucht im hohen fünfstelligen
betrag ist das nicht so witzig wenn man
überlegt dass ein normaler arbeitnehmer
von seinem arbeitgeber erzählt bekommt
dass er zwölf gehälter bitte abgeben
soll dass er ehrlich erwirtschaftet hat
dann ist das kein spaß und da muss die
politik einfach eingreifen
wie gesagt ich bin hier ein bisschen
entspannter weil ich halt auch elf jahr
gut gewirtschaftet habe und von den
rücklagen jetzt leben kann und
ausgleichen kann aber das problem
existiert definitiv und da kann ich auch
nicht sagen wenn ich zurückblicke das
ist dass er spaß mal vornehmen haben war
bin ich entspannt weil das wirklich sehr
gut anläuft seit drei wochen ich brauche
viel und dementsprechend habe ich da 22
richtungen zu bewerten dass eine nach
hinten und nach vorne an kempkens hat
auch aufmerksam zugeschaut ist das jetzt
eine glückssache da wirklich eine
stammkundschaft zu haben die natürlich
auch entsprechend geld lässt
ja das ist ja ein spezial
bereich den wir da sehen also hier
erleben wir ja dass das jemand ganz
besonders positioniert hat eine
bestimmte sparte abdeckt sich abhebt von
anderen und das ist natürlich auch die
herausforderung jetzt an diese zeit hier
jemanden der das offenbar schon vorher
gemacht hat und jetzt davon profitiert
dass wir vielleicht ja auch eine branche
haben die von der krisensituation gar
nicht so stark finanziell betroffen ist
wenn wir das in anderen bereichen haben
dann muss man um sich um positionieren
und da muss man einfach schauen dass man
neuen markenkern wirtschaft erst mal
eben auch die eigenen konzepte
hinterfragt und das finde ich eine tolle
sache und wenn wir dann so eine
marktlücke entdecken dann geht es auch
weiter
und dann kann man auch nach vorne
schauen und dann sieht man auch wie sich
das wir entwickeln und wie toll das auch
funktioniert und das ist einfach ein
typisches beispiel dafür dass wir mit
der krise auch ganz gut umgehen kann
also wir enden positiv verhört vielen
dank dass sie uns oder vielleicht auch
ihren kollegen da mut gemacht haben
tatsächlich es kommt natürlich auf den
kundenkreis an aber natürlich eine
nische zu besetzen ist natürlich auch
dann in der krise durchaus
gewinnbringend